the gta trilogy the definitive edition
has cut some cheat codes from the game
rainbow six extraction now has an
official release date and more i'm
persia and this is your gamespot news
gta the trilogy the definitive edition
features many of the original game's
cheat codes but not all of them the
updated versions of gta 3 vice city and
san andreas were developed by grove
street games using the unreal engine the
engine is apparently one of the reasons
why some of the cheat codes didn't make
the cut in gamespot's own testing we
found that the invisible cars cheat for
gta 3 does not appear to work producer
rich rosados told usa today we actually
had to remove a couple for technical
reasons certain things that didn't play
well in the unreal base but that's
actually where i'll leave it there's
some fun with discovery rosato didn't
say if any new cheat codes were added
either so apparently fans will have to
find out for themselves now that the
definitive edition is out and if you've
already hopped in and noticed some of
the assets look familiar that's because
rockstar used assets like trees and
refrigerators from grand theft auto 5
for the re-release risotto went on to
say the same is true for a lot of the
surrounding areas like the barber shops
where we also lifted assets adding later
that it was done in a way hopefully
unless i told you that was a
refrigerator from gta 5 you wouldn't
even notice because it just blends into
the background buying the definitive
edition is the only way to get all three
games together in one package however
san andreas is now on xbox game pass by
itself while gta 3 will be released
through playstation now in december
rainbow six extraction now has a release
date january 20th of 2022 each edition
of rainbow six extraction will come with
two buddypass tokens which will allow
friends to play the full game for free
for up to 14 days progression made by
players using the buddy pass tokens will
carry over to the full game should they
decide to purchase rainbow six
extraction following the trial period
the buddy tokens are across play just
like the full game so players on
different platforms will be able to use
and share buddy tokens the game will
launch with a deluxe edition that
includes everything in the standard
edition along with three bonus packs for
fifty dollars players who have played
both rainbow six siege and extraction
will receive the united front cosmetic
bundle for free which includes four
exclusive gear sets for both games and
also unlocks all 18 operators featured
in extraction for use in siege while
rainbow six extraction includes various
features from rainbow six siege ubisoft
is adamant that the two games will
appeal to different audiences with the
game's creative director saying the two
games are very different extraction
features light rpg mechanics and will
allow players to upgrade the
capabilities of each operator the full
game will include 12 maps at launch that
are said to be three times the size of
maps seen in rainbow six siege as the
title will be a live service game
ubisoft is also pledging weekly
challenges and regular content updates
the xbox app for pc is getting some much
needed updates you'll now be able to
choose which folder and drive you'd like
to install your games on before you
begin your download and overall download
speeds are said to get faster over time
which is a major quality of life
improvement another big change is
gaining access to your local files to
make it easier for you to mod your
favorite games this makes a lot of sense
with the addition of games like
minecraft being added to game pass that
already has a large modding community
you'll be able to see if a game has mod
support by checking the game description
in the app cloud gaming is also being
added to the pc app giving game pass
ultimate members instant access to tons
of games without having to download them
to your device more improvements are
being made to hdr settings and overall
app performance along with making the
process easier for developers to add
cross save and cross play features we'll
also be seeing some plugins for more
engines such as unity and more you can
sign up to be an xbox insider to test
some of these changes early by
downloading the xbox insider hub from
the microsoft website
in more app related news you can now
watch twitch on your switch the app is
released on the nintendo eshop today and
that means you can watch your favorite
streamers on the go if you don't want to
use your phone for whatever reason which
twitch channel are you watching on your
switch first let me know in the comments
below and of course leave a like and
subscribe so you don't miss your next
gamespot news update thank you all so
much for watching and we'll see you next
time
[Music]
you